Trascrizione: Alessandra Gesualdo
Revisore: Simona Donda
Voglio raccontarvi come e perché
mi sono appassionato alla demografia.
Sì, la demografia.
Lo studio delle statistiche che descrivono
le popolazioni umane
e la loro evoluzione.
Ma partiamo dall'inizio.
Sono un analista dati
e lavoro al Centro Comune di Ricerca
della Commissione Europea.
Il mio lavoro è quello
di raccogliere dati da fonti diverse,
organizzarli, strutturali ed analizzarli
per ricavarne informazioni utili
a supportare le politiche europee.
Ho iniziato lavorando sulle migrazioni,
e quando mi hanno detto
che il focus delle mie ricerche
si sarebbe dovuto spostare
dall’immigrazione alla demografia,
sono stato un po’ scettico.
Anzi, a dirla tutta ho proprio pensato
che mi sarei annoiato.
Poi però, è successo qualcosa.
Ho iniziato a lavorare
con esperti di statistica,
demografia e mercato del lavoro.
Abbiamo analizzato serie di dati
principalmente di Eurostat,
l’Ufficio statistico dell’Unione Europea.
Abbiamo studiato
il cambiamento demografico
nei paesi e nelle regioni
dell’Unione Europea
e analizzato le possibili connessioni
tra questo cambiamento e fenomeni
come lo spopolamento, la disoccupazione
e lo sviluppo economico,
ma anche con fattori
come il contesto abitativo
e il livello di educazione.
Abbiamo anche creato una piattaforma
dove visualizzare questo cambiamento
e poterlo analizzare.
E quello che ho capito
è che i dati demografici
possono servire e devono servire
per comprendere, anticipare
quella che insieme
alla transizione ecologica
e alla digitalizzazione
è la terza trasformazione
che sta plasmando il futuro dell’Europa,
ovvero il cambiamento demografico.
Sì, ma cosa sono
demografia e cambiamento demografico?
Per me, la demografia
va ben oltre lo studio
della struttura della popolazione umana:
é il mio passato, il mio presente
e il mio futuro.
La demografia é la storia della mia vita,
ma anche la storia della vita
di ognuno di voi.
Infatti le principali componenti
demografiche sono tre:
natalità, mortalità e migrazione,
dove la migrazione va intesa
nel senso più ampio di mobilità.
Io, ad esempio, sono toscano
ma da anni vivo qui.
Questo vuol dire che mi sono spostato
dal conteggio demografico di Pistoia,
la città in cui sono nato,
per spostarmi in quello di Varese,
la città in cui vivo.
Il cambiamento demografico?
Per me il cambiamento demografico
si riflette direttamente nel confronto
con il mio bisnonno Eusebio che è nato
quasi un secolo prima di me.
Eusebio, mio bisnonno paterno,
ha avuto cinque figli
il primo dei quali quando aveva 23 anni,
mentre io ho già 44 anni
e sto ancora cercando di diventare padre.
Ma la demografia tocca
quasi tutti gli aspetti della nostra vita.
Abbiamo visto tutti infatti, di recente,
come il coronavirus ha impattato
in modo diverso sulle differenti
fasce d’età della popolazione.
Qui vedete un grafico del numero di morti
associato al Covid-19 in Italia,
diviso per sesso e per fascia d’età.
E se ci pensate bene,
anche le vaccinazioni,
dopo un po’ di incertezza iniziale,
sono state organizzate
in base a dati demografici.
Potrei farvi altri esempi,
ma il punto è che la demografia
ci riguarda tutti
ed è quindi lecito pensare
che anche il cambiamento demografico
sia importante
e che avrà un impatto
su molti aspetti del nostro futuro.
Dovremo quindi iniziare
a interessarcene tutti di più.
Viviamo in un Paese, in un continente
che stanno invecchiando.
Si stima che l’età media
della popolazione nell’Unione Europea
passerà da poco più di 44 anni
a 49 anni entro il 2100.
Anche il numero di anziani
crescerà notevolmente.
Infatti, le proiezioni indicano
che il numero di ultraottantenni
salirà da 27 a 64 milioni.
Un aumento del 120 per cento.
E nel 2100 ci sarà
anche un giovanissimo in meno
ogni cento abitanti.
Infatti, la percentuale
di minori di 15 anni nell’Unione
scenderà dal 15 al 14 per cento.
E per l’Italia,
che già oggi è maglia nera in Europa,
ci sarà almeno
un piccolissimo risvolto positivo.
Dopo essere scesa all′11,
salirà al 12,5 per cento
lasciando l’ultima posizione a Malta.
Ma perché parliamo del 2100?
Sembra così lontano il 2100.
Parliamo del 2100 perché i bambini di oggi
saranno gli anziani del 2100
ed è nostro dovere pensare
a come sarà il loro futuro
e come sarà la società in cui vivranno.
Se le proiezioni mostrano
che l’Europa sta invecchiando,
le nostre analisi ci mostrano anche
che non lo sta facendo
in maniera uniforme.
Ci sono regioni che invecchiano
di più e più in fretta.
E se fino ad oggi sono state
le regioni del Sud Europa
quelle ad avere
una maggiore percentuale di anziani,
abbiamo visto che l’invecchiamento
avrà un impatto maggiore
sulle regioni del Nord Ovest
e soprattutto su quelle dell’Est Europa.
E una cosa simile
avverrà anche nelle nostre città,
specialmente a quelle di medie dimensioni
che raggiungeranno
un livello di invecchiamento
simile a quello delle aree rurali.
Ma più che il contesto urbano-rurale,
abbiamo visto che il vero fattore
legato all’invecchiamento
è lo spopolamento.
In pratica, i Paesi,
le regioni  e i comuni
che subiranno un maggior spopolamento,
saranno anche quelli
che invecchieranno di più.
E, uno dei motori trainanti
dello spopolamento
è l’assenza di opportunità di lavoro.
L’esodo dei lavoratori
più giovani e qualificati
va a bloccare il ricambio generazionale
e questo determina un invecchiamento.
C’è infatti uno stretto legame
tra questi tre fattori:
invecchiamento, spopolamento
e assenza di opportunità.
É un processo che si autoalimenta,
è già in corso
e sembra essere inarrestabile.
Un altro degli effetti
dell’invecchiamento della società
è la diminuzione della percentuale
di popolazione in età lavorativa
e il contestuale aumento delle persone
che raggiungono l’età pensionabile.
Si stima che la percentuale di persone
in età lavorativa nell’Unione Europea
scenderà di 9 punti nei prossimi 80 anni,
passando dal 64 al 55%.
Queste sono percentuali
ma, in termini assoluti,
significa che ci sarà una perdita
di 60 milioni di persone
in età lavorativa.
Praticamente,
l’intera popolazione italiana.
E quindi, se l’invecchiamento
ha un impatto diretto
sui servizi sanitari,
i servizi sociali, i sistemi pensionistici
lo ha anche sull’economia
di una certa regione.
Abbiamo visto infatti
che c’è uno stretto legame
tra la struttura
per età della popolazione
e il prodotto interno lordo pro capite
che è una misura, purché discussa,
comunemente usata per indicarne
il benessere economico.
E fin qui abbiamo visto quindi,
cosa sta succedendo
e cosa succederà in Italia e in Europa.
Però, gli scienziati
non hanno la sfera di cristallo
per vedere nel futuro.
Le proiezioni demografiche si basano
su modelli molto complessi
che a loro volta sono costruiti
su scenari definiti da un set di ipotesi.
Io vi ho mostrato quello che
Eurostat chiama Baseline Scenario,
ovvero lo scenario base,
quello di riferimento.
Ma la stessa Eurostat
ci fornisce anche differenti scenari
basati su differenti ipotesi.
Come vedete, per ogni scenario,
l’evoluzione della popolazione europea
sarà diversa, ma c’è un fattore costante
e comune a tutti e sei gli scenari,
l’invecchiamento.
Ma allora cosa dovremmo fare?
Purtroppo, soluzioni miracolose
non esistono.
Un aumento dell’immigrazione
specialmente nei paesi
che invecchiano più in fretta,
potrebbe in qualche modo
rallentare la crescita
dell’indice di dipendenza d’età.
Però, abbiamo visto che
tra il 2015 e il 2019
solo il 23% delle regioni europee
aveva un influsso netto
di persone in età lavorativa.
Un’altra possibile soluzione
sarebbe quella di aumentare
la partecipazione delle donne
al mercato del lavoro.
Questo è un punto saldo.
Di sicuro dovremmo partire da qui.
Oppure, potremmo pensare
di lavorare più a lungo
e andare in pensione più tardi.
Ma siamo davvero tutti pronti
a lavorare di più?
Una terza soluzione sarebbe quella
di cercare di stimolare la natalità,
un pò come fanno in Francia
con bonus bebè,
supporto fiscale alle famiglie
e un congedo parentale ben pagato.
Oppure come fanno in Germania
con la disponibilità
di più asili o di tate
che tengono fino a 5 bambini.
Ma forse, tutto questo
potrebbe anche non bastare.
Mentre preparavo questo discorso,
mi sono imbattuto in una notizia
del 31 maggio,
la Cina sosterrà le coppie
che vorranno avere il terzo figlio.
Beh, è una notizia storica.
Dopo anni di politica del figlio unico,
sembra che la società cinese
stia cambiando radicalmente.
Ma se la Cina e con lei
molti altri paesi nel mondo
stanno cercando di contrastare
il cambiamento demografico,
noi in Italia, in Europa,
cosa dovremmo fare?
Combattere il cambiamento demografico,
per invertire la tendenza
sembra una lotta
contro i mulini a vento.
I dati ci aiutano a comprenderlo.
Affrontarlo e sfruttarlo
per costruire una società
più equa e resiliente
che non lasci indietro nessuno.
Proviamo ad usare
il cambiamento demografico
come una scintilla
per sviluppare più prodotti e servizi
ma soprattutto per rafforzare
il ruolo attivo e positivo
di tutte le fasce d’età
all’interno della nostra società.
Per fare questo servirà
un cambiamento di mentalità.
Dovremo essere tutti
più creativi ed inclusivi,
ma soprattutto più audaci e coraggiosi.
Grazie.